over at MSNBC Brian Williams and New
York Times that are Mara gay got out the
abacus and did some math on Mike
Bloomberg's campaign last night here's
how it went when I read it tonight on
social media it kind of all became clear
Bloomberg spent five hundred million on
ads u.s. population 327 million don't
tell us if you're ahead of us on the
math he could have given each American 1
million dollars and I've had lunch money
left over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's true it's disturbing
now before we get too self-righteous we
have to admit that a lot of us went into
journalism in the first place because we
were bad at math we'd be hedge fund
moguls otherwise so we're not going to
be solving your budget crisis on this or
any other show but even so we have
producers and they're supposed to be
good at math what happened to them
where Brian Williams